well joining me now is broadcaster to
Trevor Phillips who's re-released and
updated his book Windrush 75 years of
modern Britain also in the studio talk
to these Paula Roan Adrian and Richard
Tice right there's a lot to unpack here
so Trevor you are probably the most
qualified man in the country to unpack
it with me so let me just start with
that simple question
is Britain a racist country
well as much as it pains me to agree
with you about anything Pierce
um I think actually I reached the same
conclusion as you do when you ask a
question is Britain racist country the
first thing is to ask compared to what
compared to the days when my parents
came here with their then nine children
I was the tenth born here and when my
father
said that he would have to walk the
streets at night looking for somewhere
to sleep or when we lived in two rooms
no chance of black people getting
Council houses then because Council of
tenants wouldn't have us on their states
so we lived in rachmann slums in our
family's case two rooms black family
upstairs black family downstairs uh
that's why I went that's why I was sent
back to the Caribbean because you can't
get 12 people into two rooms very
conveniently or compared to when I had
my first girlfriend at University and in
order to meet her mother we had to meet
in selfridges because her mother
couldn't tell her father that her
daughter date was dating somebody black
so I think when people say you know it's
terrible races just talk to your parents
or to talk to your grandparents now that
doesn't mean we're perfect but if you
survey people now on the uh Think Tank
British future did this a couple of
weeks ago eighty percent of people from
ethnic minorities will tell you that
compared to anywhere in the content
continent and by the way compared to the
United States this is a better place to
live if you are not white than anywhere
else in the development when I walk up
and down my local High Street maybe a
couple of times a day it just seems
unbelievably Multicultural London I mean
I don't Venture North a lot when I do it
doesn't feel a lot different actually
when I go to Manchester or places like
that
um it just feels like we live in an
incredibly tolerant Multicultural
environment now I think there are
racists in Britain no question as there
are in every country but my God we've
come a long way I think from that
environment your parents had to come to
yeah I mean let's study on a bit I mean
let's the fact that there are many races
in this country that does doesn't make
us a racist Nation but but that doesn't
mean that we don't have problems we
don't have a situation where people who
look like me know that when they go for
a job people will smile at them and be
very lovely to them and as soon as they
walk out the door say hello not not
going to have that one because they
won't fit Let me Give an example all
sorts of reasons Let me Give an example
I remember watching players like Luther
blissett one of the first black
footballers then John Barnes and others
I remember the monkey chants from The
Terraces I remember the bananas being
thrown on not how they remember it they
were on the receiving end I remember
watching it
and you would never see that in an
English professional game now I mean
this is unheard of you hear about it in
Spain still and countries like that but
not here and I was really struck by for
example the taking the knee the George
Floyd it was it was divisive and
controversial for many people but I
gotta say arsenal for example very
Multicultural uh crowd a lot of black
players Mikaya sacker and others it was
always they did it for the whole time
that it went on for the whole season it
was immaculately heard by the Home and
Away crowds I never heard a single boo
now I don't think that would have
happened
even 20 years ago I I think that is true
and you know an Arsenal as a sort of
very polite nice club I mean not a
winning Club but a very nice club uh if
if you went went to uh Chelsea which is
yeah had been my club for more than half
a century
um when I was a student I stopped going
because of the racism yeah because they
were throwing darts and I was like the I
was like the bullseye in the dartboard
right so I stopped going for a long time
but today you wouldn't get any of that
in Chelsea in fact well you've had the
occasional but it when it happens it's
really it becomes a big story exactly
it's nothing like the old days when we
had you know the Headhunters and all
that business today our heroes are
Didier Drogba uh kante I mean this is a
whole the country itself has changed and
by the way those people that you saw
coming down the Gangplank from Windrush
they were the people who changed things
they no wait okay so let's move to
something like and I totally agree with
you by the way let's move to qriket
right now you have a vested interest I
think in the recruitment process for the
chair of this inquiry which has come out
with a pretty damning 317-page report
holding up a mirror to qriket which has
concluded a structural and institutional
racism existing within the game women
are treated as subordinate to men at all
levels of the sport there's elitism and
class-based discrimination in qriket now
and says black Cricket has been failed
and ecmb must develop a plan to revive
it I don't think people would in the
game would disagree with with that um
assessment some are horrified I mean
quite surprised and shocked on some of
them and I'll come to the racial part in
a moment with you but on the on the part
for example about elitism I remember
when I was 12 I got picked for the
England prep schools Cricket Squad I was
a fast bowler loved Dennis Lilly and I
was very good for my age but I was
playing Cricket three hours a day I was
being trained at my Prep School by
former Hampshire cricketer and I had the
benefit of that privilege and elitist
experience if you like and then I went
to local comprehensive where they
literally play cricket once a week for
two hours if they could find any of the
meager equipment that they had for all
the children and if a teacher could be
bothered to do it which often wasn't the
case so I went from playing three hours
a day to nothing and it seems to me we
we could be the world beaters all the
time at Cricket Miss country if State
schools had anything like the commitment
which would have to come I guess from
Government funding to things like
Cricket which they just don't I mean
they don't so the chances of breaking
through past the more privileged elitist
private school system as a cricketer
they're pretty low yeah and I think the
basic Point here is I mean I I grew up I
was born here but I grew up in the
Caribbean where Cricket is you know it's
it's there's the air and there's water
and then there's Cricket yeah and they
float they all flow through the Village
um you have we play cricket in the
streets here they play and you know
they'll have Nets at the moment we don't
have any of that in this country and
it's not a surprise then that people
will uh if they're any good if they're
athletic they'll do basketball girls
will play netball the boys will play
football I think I think that this is a
terrible thing to be honest because I
think Cricket is a fantastic sport for
teaching you disciplines uh for teaching
your team uh teamwork and talk and if I
may say so Cindy Butts who chaired this
inquiry
um I was delighted that she took on the
role because we were asked to find
somebody to do it and she's done a
fantastic job the thing about what she
has said
people need to remember Cricket is more
than a game and okay it's you know I'm a
Western Indian uh that's a religion it's
a religion the Creator is more than a
game but it it also tells you something
about the society the greatest book
about sport ever written beyond the
boundary by Trinidadian intellectual uh
tlr James essentially showed that what
happens in the world is paralleled on
the field so for example 60 years ago in
this country we used to have a thing
called Gentleman versus pledge yeah well
you were born
yeah exactly the gentleman had their own
Gates yeah yeah exactly the gentleman
were Posh guys who only played for
expenses went through that one gate to
the Pavilion the players were
professionals they went through the
other gate and they worked for a salary
the last game between gentlemen players
Captain the general captured by Lord Ted
Dexter uh the the the players were
captained by Fred Truman son of a minor
when they got rid of gentlemen versus
players that was announcing that Britain
had left that kind of class divide to
some extent behind it and I think what
Cindy's report is doing is something
equally profound saying Britain needs to
leave behind the hidden class divisions
plus the divisions particularly between
men and women
all fast learning stuff
um Paula is Britain a racist country
ah
there are parts of Britain that remain
of the view that people who look like me
shouldn't be here
there are parts of Britain who are
prepared to challenge that view and that
is why we can have the McPherson report
that is why we have the reports that we
do today that come out about Cricket
that is why we can challenge the
Metropolitan Police the London fire
brigade et cetera Etc so um we have
unfortunately lots of individuals who
can give you their experience we
unfortunately have institutions that
have been identified as still well
example and it's hard to think of a more
damaging thing than to have your main
police force in the country condemned as
institutionally racist I mean Richard
this is part of the problem there are
certainly still institutions where you
can just feel that the setup is geared
towards being accused of in many cases
quite rightly institutional racism of a
degree and you highlight the Met police
and we all know there's an ABS absolute
horror stories within that institution
you touched on the fire brigade these
are public sector institutions I think
there's far more progress and overall I
don't think we are a racist country I
think we should celebrate the incredible
progress we've made but there are
pockets of it what troubles me most is
those pockets are in the public sector
just coming back to the cricket pits
there are things actually again that I
don't think the report does Justice to
my son plays in an Oxford League okay
there are many teams there where there
are either 100 percent uh Asian uh
ethnicity within the team or the vast
majority of it again I don't think that
is celebrated enough and appreciate
enough so we're making great progress
there's always more to do but for him to
say let's look at the positives not just
beat ourselves what did you feel about
some Paul's Cathedral having this thing
on their website what turned out to be a
long time labeling Winston Churchill or
white supremacist I just I just think
that's it's appalling which is one of
the greatest heroes he saved this
country from the ultimate most hideous
white supremacist out of Hitler For
Heaven's Sake and we should be
celebrating and thanking that and for
sure he made mistakes we all do but we
are so much better
racist mistakes Richard I wasn't around
at the time you know what the history
books tell us were those mistakes racist
in today's in today's world we would say
definitely in in the context of then who
knows what it was we weren't around
for us to address that well I thought
Ian Wilson got a great piece to live for
the male when he said that you have to
take all these people like Churchill
Gandhi Mandela in the totality of what
they achieved what is what is hit uh
Churchill's greatest achievement it was
defeating Hitler the ultimate white
supremacist so I mean Trevor it's
complicated but obviously some of the
things that Churchill said over the
years were racially tinged there's no
question of that
um which was of its time I mean those
kind of comments were not unusual but I
don't think he was a white supremacist
well I think these these phrases are
hurled around as phrases of abuse let's
be clear I mean Churchill for example
you mentioned Gandhi uh Churchill I
think described uh Gandhi as half-naked
Indian fakir a kind of pejorative
dismissive terms but that was a nature
of the English aristocracy at the time
yeah and that was without question a
racist point of view but the important
point is that it was normal and that's
actually I don't I feel really
uncomfortable Paula when we try and
transport the morality of the day back
to previous generations and this brings
me to well I was going to say what what
it should tell us is
it was like that then goodness me now
it's unacceptable now it's unacceptable
and we should really be thinking
constantly
how have we moved this right but this on
that point though Paula this issue of
reparations for example you know people
today paying for the sins of their
ancestors who may have owned slaves
there was an extraordinary Reuters
report today quite I mean hilarious in
some ways do you know who the only
American they charted every American
president's links to slave ownership do
you know the only one who had no direct
links to slave ownership
Donald Trump
you know
they don't even Barack Obama threw his
white side of the family they could
chart it back to slave ownership Trump
is the only one apparently came after
slavery his his life and we've discussed
reparations before and you know my view
I'm very uncomfortable about the fact
that the British government felt it
appropriate that they should pay back
the slave owners and only finished
compensating them in 2015 and yet when
we talk about reparations to those still
affected by colonialism we are told to
shut down that conversation and that
comes back to what we're discussing
about Winston Churchill if people
understood that Winston Churchill did
say things that were inappropriate the
Winston Churchill did say things or held
views that were racist it's fine to
encapsulate them in at a point of
History
we don't know we're not hearing don't
take a place that supports cathedral
which literally was an emblem of the
blitz for goodness sake right when
Churchill stood up and basically
single-handedly motivated this country
to defeat a bunch of white supremacists
from taking us over Trevor can I just
say on that point I do apologize for
interrupting there are a lot of people
in this country who think that black
people arrived on the Wind Rush that was
that was us stepping into this world
that's not true
we were here long before this I realized
you realize that a lot of people don't
know it's the same in regards to the
history okay let me ask let me ask
Trevor a interesting question in an
interview with a male that you gave you
made the point you were very
disappointed that Megan and Harry had
had this amazing opportunity yeah as the
first biracial couple in our monarchy to
really be a force for Change and good
and they blew it yeah by the way I'm not
going to let you get away with the whole
Trump thing still not voting for him
right by the way I've never told anyone
to vote for Donald Trump right I'm not
American I wouldn't impinge on their
thing it just was quite funny he read
this report and he was the only one I've
got it I've got a lot of American four
sisters who live in New York and they've
got a view about Trump but anyway
um on the Meghan Markle thing look
I think people mistake who Meghan Markle
is
um
she herself said that until she became
this princess she never regarded herself
particularly as black and that's
understandable she grew up uh in Los
Angeles in the most uh wealthy uh black
enclave and anywhere in the United
States Park
um Park View Windsor Hill in Los Angeles
she went to a private uh Roman Catholic
school and in a sense race was never
really part of her background and
actually you knew anybody who from back
from who comes from a black family knew
that this was not her territory when she
made this supposedly incendiary Claim
about somebody asking about what
Archie's skin color will be well
actually every black family of course
the minute that that you know there's
somebody coming that's what you're
speculating about for white people it's
what color hair
particularly in a family if one parent
is right yeah and one parent is black
but as in her parents for example but
the point I really want to make about
Meghan Markle is that she had to learn
to be black on the job as it were and I
think she made a bit of a mess of it she
didn't take advice and that's in some
sense is why I think they've squandered
the opportunity right to demonstrate
something important about this country
but just very quickly yeah we have the
largest uh unique uh uniquely mixed race
population anywhere in the developed
world that has come about through
romance Robin coercion and they could
have been standards I totally agree
you're grimacing I'm quickly because I I
obviously I love so Trevor but we're
going to disagree on that point you
yourself have just said she did a bad
job of learning how to be black why did
this woman this person have to learn how
to be black she had to be learned how to
be black because she had to confront
racists and it was the first time that
she was
there are people in prison now because
of the threats they made to her life and
peers I know you are sensitive to people
who have made threats to people's lives
you will understand that mental strain
that was on her in terms of that and you
know that because you will have read the
reports confront tell me the name of one
person that she confronted she didn't
even hear this remark about Archie it
was reported to her by her I'm
referencing
of police Terror police Neil Bassey who
was interviewed and he informed the
viewer that she had um received a number
of threats to him
I have had a few so far right and they
have been arrested for that and charged
and guilty did she so in terms of that
in terms of that she confronted racism
no she didn't she confronted confronted
threats which we all get in public life
to do with that I've got to leave with
the skin
it's an important subject thank you for
all your perspectives I appreciate it
Trevor uh great to see you again and
good luck with the book Windrush 75
years of modern Britain a cracking read